we now have our teachers the people who
are supposed to be educating our
students
crying
on video on the internet
because their their students might
cough on them
if i die
who's going to take care of my children
and if i end up in the hospital how am i
going to pay those bills
and if i give covet to my students
or my own children and they die
how am i gonna live with that
and i want you to ask any teacher
how they feel this year and i'm sure
that they will tell you that they have
never experienced anxiety like this
because it is like we are trying to
protect our students from a mass
shooting that we know is coming but
cannot do anything about except we can
do something about it it's just that not
everyone agrees
that wearing a mask will stop the
onslaught of students and staff who are
likely to become sick and that makes me
sick
i think this lady is making a pretty
good argument for this she session she's
making a pretty good argument against
she covered because this lady should not
should not be working in public this she
is not
she is not psychologically fit to do it
if you're crying over the prospect that
one of your students might cough on you
and might spread the germs that
statistically you have virtually
virtually no chance of facing serious
complications from a minuscule
infinitesimally small chance of facing
serious complications from and your
students have an even lower chance
you are not fit
to be certainly not to be teaching
anybody but probably not fit to even be
in public life this is this is a fragile
broken deluded person
and she says that first of all first of
all children die of the flu
children face serious complications
sometimes from the flu this woman
assuming she's taught in the years
before kovid
has gone to school during flu season
without a mask
without
bottles of purell everywhere the unholy
water of our new religion our religion
of public health
uh she she's done that and it's fine and
she hasn't she hasn't been waking up in
a cold sweat
under the horrible thought that she
might have given the flu to her student
or vice versa
now
with the coronavirus which is around us
she says she can't the thought that you
would go to school without a mask it's
terrible because if we just wear a mask
then the virus won't spread except we
found out the virus spreads even with
the mask
the virus
spreads even with the vaccine
the virus spread it's a virus that's
what happens
we had very serious lockdowns in this
country the virus continued to spread
actually
beyond our cut i should give this lady a
break because she's not even the
kookiest on this topic
i'm glad you like that clip you can get
the whole show on apple podcasts spotify
google play stitcher for free it's the
michael knowles show type it in search
it in right now in your podcast app
subscribe
maybe leave a five star review i don't
know i really appreciate it helps us get
around some of the big tech censorship
that occasionally exists around here see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]